en un nuevo intento de silenciar a sus
críticos el presidente Daniel Ortega
ordenó a los agentes antidisturbios
impedir al obispo Rolando Álvarez salir
de la casa cural de matagalpa en el
norte de Nicaragua para oficiar una
eucaristía
herido salir
nos encontramos aquí seis sacerdotes
seis largos que nos tienen encerrados en
la furia episcopal Aquí vamos a
permanecer sin ir y respetar a la
policía nunca la hemos irrespetado
Álvarez acusa al presidente Daniel
Ortega de querer una iglesia muda para
que no denuncien las injusticias en el
país el lunes el obispo informó de
hostigamientos por parte de la policía y
denunció el cierre de cinco radios de su
diócesis en matagalpa por supuestas
ilegalidades que él rechaza algo que
alarmó a las organizaciones de Derechos
Humanos
la oficina del alto comisionado de las
Naciones Unidas para los derechos
humanos de América Central llama al
Estado a cesar de inmediato el
hostigamiento y los ataques contra
sacerdotes feligreses y estaciones de
radio y televisión de la Iglesia
Católica es urgente proteger la
integridad física la libertad religiosa
y la libertad de expresión de todas las
personas la clausura de estos medios se
suma al cierre en junio pasado del Canal
de la conferencia episcopal así como de
TV Merced y el canal católico San José
de Estelí las relaciones entre la
Iglesia Católica y el gobierno de Ortega
se han deteriorado desde 2018 cuando
hubo protestas contra la administración
del mandatario y una posterior represión
por parte del gobierno